um there's something freeing right about
being vulnerable like that sometimes and
actually opening up with your story i
feel like that's the only time i
actually get through my pain is when i
share it oddly enough do y'all feel like
that
i don't share my pain
i keep it all in and save it for comedy
it's an amazing story man thank you yeah
really awesome do you do that you do you
find that he shares this pain obviously
i know i love it i love it but i find
that even as a songwriter like whenever
like people are like man you're very
open i'm like honestly it's not for
y'all it's for me it's like my outlet of
getting it out like i feel like that's
helpful for me is that helpful for you
that's helpful yeah i always uh i i
didn't believe in talking to somebody
before you know how i deal with it was
oh if i'm stressed out or if i'm running
into something i'll i'll tend to find a
solution and execute it and solve it but
now i know that you know talking with
someone and surrounded by you know a
group of like positive people is so
important and words are really powerful
too yeah right gosh i'm what i want him
to adopt me now i know every every time
you talk i've learned something
[Music]
you